la advertencia fue lanzada por el jefe
de la otan
bahamut podría caer en manos del
ejército Ruso y del grupo paramilitar
Wagner en los próximos días
no podemos excluir que baku caiga
finalmente en los próximos días es
importante subrayar que esto no refleja
necesariamente un punto de inflexión en
la guerra Solo subraya que no hay que
subestimar a Rusia estas declaraciones
llegan horas después de que jeffeny
trigo gym jefe del grupo paramilitar
Wagner afirmara que sus hombres han
capturado toda la zona este de la ciudad
los regimientos del grupo Wagner han
tomado todo el este debate del río
backmut está totalmente controlado por
el grupo Wagner se puede informar de
esto
y es que ante el temor de que la caída
debajo deje vía libre a los rusos para
apoderarse de otras ciudades del este de
Ucrania el presidente
espera la entrega de nuevas armas
occidentales ha dejado Claro en una
entrevista con CNN que su ejército No
cederá ni un centímetro de la ciudad las
preocupaciones de selenski sobre los
avances rusos parecen fundados
Moscú dice que la captura de bajo es
necesaria para la continuación de su
ofensiva en las últimas semanas los
soldados rusos han realizado pequeños
avances y ahora parecen controlar el
acceso a la ciudad por el norte el sur y
el este creando La amenaza de un cerco
aunque se cuestiona el valor estratégico
de bahamut la ciudad ha adquirido una
innegable importancia simbólica como
resultado de los esfuerzos de ambos
bandos desde el verano pasado para
controlarla